so
shikari richardson accepted a one-month
suspension after testing positive for
marijuana usada announced since the
tournament the fan favorite athlete has
apologized richardson 21 a minute that
she used marijuana
after finding out her biological mother
died from a report from a reporter prior
to competing in olympic trials nike the
brand that sponsored richardson
responded we appreciate shikari
shikari's honesty and accountability and
we will continue to support her through
this time
the company said in a statement on june
19 shikari punched her ticket for tokyo
olympics with a dominant one at the u.s
olympic track and field trials
in oregon the athlete recorded a time of
10.86 seconds
in a hundred meter race earning a spot
on her first ever olympic team usada
revealed
in the statement that richardson results
on june 19 which
included includes her olympic qualifying
results have been disqualified
gerard oh my god listen we are living in
a bizarro time man we are living in the
craziest times of all time
where somebody who smokes weed can't
compete but a biological man can compete
against women and that's not a problem
at all
that's not that's nobody nobody has
anything to say about that where a
biological man can can go weight lift
against women
no issue whatsoever okay but somebody
smokes a little bit of weed
all right in in in probably a state
where it's completely legal now
and they can't represent their country
like it's outrageous to me on the left
the levels of hypocrisy that are in our
beer
our bureaucratic systems right now are
insane they're insane to me now
if if you are able to run 100 meters in
under 11 seconds
while you're high giving her an extra
medal give her a green medal
are you kidding me like all i don't
smoke weed because i don't need
any uh motivation for the state to be
lazy
i smoke weed i'm eating cookies i'm not
running a hundred meters you know what
i'm saying like dude
this is crazy by the way by the way let
me ask you this but the idea that they
suspended her for a month
good bad bad grow up why though why is
it bad
why is it bad what what is the what is
the object of it is the object to be a
deterrent for
children like what what what let me ask
you this let me ask you a question so
you know the whole thing with reggie
bush how
it's like now i deserve my heisman back
because of what you did now it's legal
so you should give it back to me right
at the time when he did it
it was illegal how does the law work i
agree with what i'm asking you is
at the time when you did it that was a
law you broke right so prohibition used
to be illegal if you did it
at that time you went to jail so people
finally said listen this is a terrible
idea man
we cannot be doing this so is it
something where you did break the law we
have to keep it or else because someone
in the future is going to come back and
say
you let shakari down you know you let
her get away with it what's what's wrong
with what i'm doing
what's the difference between me using
steroids and her use smoking marijuana
both of them were illegal at the same
time
the problem is is that she's supposed to
be able to run on the relay team
and to me it's like well if she can run
on the relay team
why not the 100 meters so i went on
twitter and i asked and a lot of people
said well
it's the timing of the one month
suspension and i thought well
to me that doesn't make any sense it
should be all or nothing
you know like she's gonna do well at the
relay we already know that
but to me she should be able to run in
100 meters maybe she was just training
passing the duchy bro like that
was just the old relay at the end of the
day i give her mad props for actually
showing accountability
and actually saying why she was doing it
in the first place my biggest issue
is who was in her camp prior to this
there has to be some handler that says
okay she's going through this this and
this
you're going to be tested around this
time like who doesn't know the freaking
testing schedule
so that you can give the ioc a heads up
hey we have this
is there a way that we could write an
exemption
because of why she was doing it it was
prescribed or whatever it is
but for them to just say you got pop
this and that is like who are handling
these athletes
you got to be better about this because
now she's
not going to be able to entertain yeah
not be able to represent the country
in that event that we were all in shock
over
you know her performance now it's even
crazier you're still a high level
competitor
i i competed everybody here knows people
that competed right
they have no problem pumping us full of
drugs
full of drugs right like i played an
entire
season getting shots in my shoulder
every like i couldn't
i could not i was an all-star in 2009 i
could not wash my hair after the games
you're supposed to take like 100
milligrams of celebrities a day i was up
to a thousand milligrams by freaking
by by uh by batting practice man i'm
getting shots in my shoulder once a
month
and you know my body's just shutting
down but i'm playing well and in that
level if you're not on the field
somebody's taking your job you know what
i'm saying
so like if she blew her hamstring out
they would have
no problem whatsoever injecting her with
a chemical cocktail
like no problem whatsoever and that
would be okay yeah right but she smokes
weed and it's like whoa
whoa whoa then where's the person who
look like we talk about the nba and
other athletes being able to do this now
right
where's the person that coming up for
the olympics that says you know what in
basketball they're not really testing
for this
and i'm sure they're not testing the nba
guys that are going to be traveling for
the olympic team
i would be smartest thing david stern
ever did right so
so what baseball did with their testing
was like yeah we're not doing right so
are we testing the nba guys
who by the way who's suspended or usada
suspended or right yeah
yeah usada and you have wada those those
are the two different what do they stand
for what does usada stand for
world anti-doping agency as well and
they they're supposed to handle otto
yeah now there's now what's crazy about
wada i think that this is like one of
the lesser known things everybody uh
hates on uh
lance armstrong they did retroactive
testing once they found out that that
you know these guys were were you know
isotope testing so what people don't
know lance armstrong with the livestrong
right
yeah he the biggest cheater of all time
this guy let america down how dare he
if i'm now i could be wrong because i'm
going outside my head but if i remember
correctly
when they did retroactive testing on
lance armstrong you would have had to
have gone to like 27th or 28th
place in the tour de france before
defaults before you found somebody
who didn't have uh extra levels of you
said the top 25 people were doing at
least they were all he did so
he got caught he wasn't just landing he
was juicing better than the rest of them
so here's the question though
does reggie bush deserve his heisman
back oh i don't
i don't think so no okay i don't think
so why well because
usc was playing under different rules
than the other competition
i don't think smoking marijuana gives
you an advantage over the competition i
think
paying players for recruiting the best
talent when your other
people aren't does give you an advantage
over the competition i think that one
isn't the same as the other in that
regard i actually agree with you about
reggie bush i think reggie bush just has
to wear it i don't think it's right that
the
player is going to get paid but he has
to wear it and what you're talking about
goes back to like
it's the laws of man versus the laws of
nature this is something
this is the craziest day ever democrats
actually get right man this is
something that they like slavery was
legal
it was legal doesn't make it moral
right the fact that there's people we've
talked about this said this is the third
time i'm i'm talking this
on your podcast the fact that there is
legal weed
being sold today and there are people in
jail for the rest of their lives for
selling weed
is a moral it's it's something that we
all have to come to grips with this is
immoral this is wrong this is something
that that
i don't even smoke weed and i'm telling
you the fact that there are corporations
that are making
billions of dollars off of this plan
while there's other people that are
going to spend the rest of their life in
prison is wrong
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye